First, I want you to know that this experiment was completely safe. The baby
couldn't fall. The plexiglass could hold the baby's weight, and they also had a
barrier around the sides of the platform. I didn't draw it here, that way, you
could see the cute baby. This demonstrates to us that by the time the baby can
crawl, he or she has developed the ability to perceive depth. We know this
because they won't go over the cliff. If they couldn't tell depth, they would
just keep going. That's cool, right? We learned more about sensation and
perception studies during the earlier sensation and perception lesson. So, we
just wanted to cover some of the interesting facts regarding human development.
There's always more you can learn about sensation and perception development.
If you want, you can check out the open source text. Just click on the link
below. Or you can always raise questions in the forums. But for now, let's move
on to cognitive development with Susan.